what's up everybody welcome to megabit
it's monday at gamespot it's 11am on the
west coast maxell McGee ready to place
some risen and evil wake up max I'm
right you're right yeah we're to play
Resident Evil on gamecube is a remake
that Capcom did part of their exclusive
deal with Nintendo back in the day to
support the gamecube didn't last very
long resident evil eventually came back
to the ps2 the resident evil 4 very true
and resume before was just too dang
pocket to day and good we're gonna jump
into the game this is one of the best
looking games on the gamecube and i love
it i haven't played in a long time
though did you place when it came out oh
my goodness are you talking about like
original resident evil back in 96 games
the games you grooving to know i did not
play the gamecube version sadly never
actually owned a gamecube i had a friend
of mine tyson to gamecube and of course
like everyone who owned a gamecube yet
smash brothers and random star wars game
that he played like three or four times
all right sadly no you've never played
this before I've no I've seen it but I
okay all right now well ok I played a
ritual resident evil oh yeah yeah well
the the way that they did the the
graphics in this game are amazing cuz
pre-rendered backgrounds again yeah all
the polygons power went towards the
character models sonic on power that
yeah trademark yeah TV restricted so
okay jeweler I know I know I know it's a
big well Chris cuz you get nerd in this
don't you get you get for it haven't
brought them out yet what's the
difference in the two characters
remember one of them gets more ammo I
think Chris gets Boyle has Jill get
together and chris has probably a knife
so let's go chill all right
look how spooky that text is and that
inner cap tea on Valentine so go then we
have all these lights on in here I know
it's really good for us let's go in with
West Raccoon City we are searching for
the helicopter of our compatriots
bravoteens disappeared during the middle
of their mission bravoteens
bizarre murder cases have recently
occurred in Raccoon City their
outlandish reports of families being
attacked by a group of about 10 people
victims families hardly
the bravo team was sent in to
investigate but we lost contact look
Chris Bravo teams helicopter was a
derelict dad his loving the decision
please Jill by the way good safer from
one side done something right in the
show did you uh do you rem the original
opening the original game it was all
well first it was all live action it was
all I've xeg nonsense they had like
intros for every character we would be
like turn the name like Wesker the actor
would like turn around or this gun today
I'm Wesker it's like some seventies
action show or so how are we gonna see
some lesbians in true some old-school
way through I love this first got there
GoPro cams I don't know mama go love how
Jill's like eyes have no pigment
whatsoever
now dude whew just a tree oh come on
Joseph my Joseph what's gonna happen the
suspense blarg Oh No all right Wesker
West be fighting
I prefer like pre trenchcoat Western so
on the murder can what votans like pre
matrix Wesker you mean yeah before he
had magic zombie kombu powers yeah oh
boy I messed up feels like no I'm not
feeling about this i'm not really sure
what's happening which I'm scared what's
a copy Oh dog I can't shoot a puppy okay
wait I'm gonna go with scared okay huh
grass
quick a mansion
that one dog is the leader of the pack
no dog is this way catch it thanks
Wesker yeah wasn't he with them and then
all of a sudden he was like because we
are the head a zombie powers I forgot a
tiger uppercut one of them higher hear
that rumor that you GM put out in car
isn't evil to where you could find Akuma
in like a cryo like chamber on the game
and you could unlock him I always wanted
that to be true they had a really good
convincing like mock-up screenshots how
about I in Adam wax the floor right
before you guys got here too it's nice
all right back to tank controls it's
been a long time since I played hey
Barry Barry not quite your ordinary
house that's for sure shut up no my was
my skirt where's Chris Sheva Jill know
you don't want to go back out there and
I don't want to move my mouth any more
than necessary yeah Chris no no going
investigate dealing with her
person are you can call me Barry all
right you two go I'll secure this area
Andy's graphic displays what I would
love an HD port of this game I think
it's charming no I mean I like it as it
everything is oh I just forget the AoE
yeah I mean you could run it on an
emulator and just a Leo through you're
right exactly yeah if you're in this on
the emulator you could apply all sorts a
nice effects to it the motion blur times
alright it's just a dining table so is
it the clock on the second story of this
room that you can move oh don't ask me
specific max my memories of the game or
more like conceptual feelings they're
not so much specific detailed analyses
knocking typewriters it's an old
typewriter what's an old type I don't
have a memory card so no longer than so
LOLOL no no remember I just thinking up
an ink ribbon so let's all make sure
that I die it he doesn't die because
otherwise we're gonna be a lot of
trouble yeah well if I die I'll start
over as Chris right there you go a lot
of goodness I think you'd better take a
look at this good be more races I think
it's strawberry jam well somebody spoke
ketchup oven floor is it ketchup I with
the lockers do this what if it's cats up
fine in the other maybe some mustard you
got yourself a sandwich go speaking of
sandwiches yeah oh yes of course yes I
like how they actually gave Jill pants
in this game that's right yeah
she's earned them how this tank controls
doing they're doing doing I'd like to
not talk about it man just the the
shadows and the lighting in this game
just so [ __ ] good excuse the language
pardon my french but GD it so good chris
is that you Chris Chris I'm talking to
you off of that other dude Barry found
some clues need some lotion bro and
wasn't you know where the crap out of me
you know doing it away from him I
remember playing this game the original
version with a friend did they or it is
how it something like old man when I get
a playstation I'm gonna give me some
resident evil but I was like nine and
then when I finally got the game and
tried playing on my own I was like nope
can't do this nope can't handle me too
buddy my name is Barry he it'll bury
I'll bury wait a man up I like that I
know he shot him twice it was like I
gotta aim real carefully for this last
one it wasn't cool if you pulled like a
like a like an ocelot thing mm-hmm metal
gear you want to like Toros gunner Wow
and then a whole bunch of other berries
like come out of the woodwork all right
Larry never lets his prey escape better
report back to El you're right I should
shouldn't I would you find another clue
when you found that zombies yeah telling
you one of these clocks can move you was
really good at resident evil is Francis
really one of the community people the
social team she basically it was master
of tank control it was the only game
that she had on PlayStation 4 years so
she is a like we played the DualShock
director's cut version on like a 24 hour
stream let's back and she basically
played two hours straight doing
everything like she was like no like
point to point exactly where to go there
move that secret behind there it was
great and I never know she like street
fighter but I never seen her really like
play games before so like I knew she
liked games but it was just crazy to see
that in action to see see how good she
was to see her true abilities yeah power
level all right do do do the wait can I
know I don't have to just like the way
you're supposed yes search the go up the
stairs so you have useful advice
goddammit look how useful i'm not a tank
i'm a real person wesker's over here no
hmm no that still just the door only we
had radios and communicate with one
another I mean these GoPro cams are nice
and all but why did the department spend
all their money on these gopro cam I
told him it was a bad idea I told we
didn't we still don't have
walkie-talkies wesker's got that thing
in his ear I guess he was the only one
who brought one tick he's like Bluetooth
pc has been as a tank I'm not so good so
then way if you play is Oh in those
reflections oh look at that reflection
this is 2002 tech right there dude
there's no way they had that in 96 I
just yeah I'm so good it's so great
seeing just fixed camera angles again I
kind of like him in my old friend fixed
I dig it i don't i don't see why just
because we can do something that's
technically better that this is then a
bad way to design a game i think it just
you know it it has its weaknesses right
but at the same time like you can't
really see what's coming which what's
coming you don't really have very any
luck jewel no nothing I would have told
you that's all you can't figure it out
same here
Chris any luck yeah I found I found
Wesker's not much we can do we can
search for him separately I'll investing
oh yeah let's split up that's always a
good outlook I'll try the door on the
other side cool lets me back here at
some point it easily you lost let's
start from the first floor okay oh I
almost forgot it's a lot big you'd make
better use of it why because chills
master unlocking but Barry just thanks
he does like has a lockpick but for no
real reason you can't use thing happens
let's meet up in this hall yeah you know
there's something happens on the third
floor like a half way done the meetups
in the hall just make sure that yeah
make sure you carry yourself down back
down to the hall and I'll just assume
that something happened and show up
it'll be good ok yeah ok yeah if you get
hurt come back down to the hall and it
may be like if I get her to or a couple
hours go by or whatever I'll come back
down eventually we'll play it by ear
yeah let's play by ear get that thing
get that's bro it's not time yet it's
not time yet I need to go maybe become a
sandwich I think I was gonna say you
don't have very good there's no I trying
to say like fluid movement between the
different shots ok if you want to have a
height like some like a high-speed
third-person action shooter game right
having like that' crysis 3 yeah and
you're constantly like just running
through two different shots right higher
and having to reorient yourself over and
over again yet come in I was so excited
to get Dino Crisis 3 better work you
were super hype about all right guys I'd
played like 10 minutes of it and I was
like Jetpack dinosaurs dinosaurs base
like it's not what's not to love right
it's got everything oh man but that game
also has everything in terms of problems
such as infinitely responding enemies
Jill yeah look I need you to this is
what you want me to do right come on
Jill come on come on come on Jill you
can do it she really doesn't want to get
off your top of it well just hop off in
there there you go he's a real sweet
girl just kind of confused a lot of the
time how do I push this
why won't it let me push it nope damn it
all right I'm going to the menu that's
what I thought but it's not
hmm because I need to get to I need to
push it to get the thing you know Peter
in honor of the Game Boy turning 25 we
have been playing the game boy version
Oh No present evil today no we shouldn't
have okay yeah yeah man imagine first
off how do we even because there's no
way you can get video out of the
original game yeah well you max max the
show you have little knowledge oh no no
no no you could get the Superboy the
super Game Boy and plug it into your
restaurant I guess yeah or come on we're
or into the Super Nintendo no there's
another better option what's the no I
would be one that involves component
video Wyatt you could you could could
you plug it in the gamecube you could
plug into the gamecube happy tell me
about what was what was the thing you
needed a gameboy player was there like a
special yes it slapped onto the bottom
oh oh no it did didn't it yes okay I
remember this guy okay okay all right
but you got to get this whole boy
remember be like fairy damn it be like
bury it all about my name is Jill oh you
lost your knife no I got infinite knives
oh you stabbed him in the face well he's
kind of a jerk all right yeah I guess
its face his face little did you'll know
that years later she would be able to
shoot zombies in the knee and then do
matrix come through moves to somersault
kick ya like I don't believe he's dead
probably on yeah he's he's very much
alive make sure you aim for the hands
make sure I run out of bullets as soon
as possible keys step on the moon once
there downs yeah but I don't know that I
guess I'd have to get your knife back I
still got my knife yeah oh man okay how
do I have to okay wait oh okay the door
with the sword right isn't that the
story it's an embryo the sword hmm sure
people in the chatter yelling at me
right now oh no I got nothing well they
haven't caught up yet the chance a
little bit behind oh I liked it isn't
there a button there oh yeah you were
talking about your setup and playing
survival horror games I feel like we all
had our own special little setup like
when you were sitting down to play a
[ __ ] again you went through certain
rituals yeah to make it especially
spooky I make sure to just avoid my
bowels boys about ahead of time usually
go down to the basement if applicable
well that's what I did I would play down
India in the bed out of the depths we
had an old musty recliner chair and a
bunch of houseplants that we would keep
down there and I'd surround myself with
a houseplant iconic on the common like
the video game jungle all right Barry
something happened where are you Barry I
know we're ready to meet back in the
lobby Barry said why can't you okay here
we go
net me here we go back again I feel like
I'm supposed to be able to push the
table but when I'm are good but I need
to be able to push it like forward what
if you just shot the fashion I don't
think that that probably could resume
before in front shoot the thing to knock
the thing down button to push it a
little bit Jill I'm where you're going
all the way now if you're pushing it all
the way isn't she come on waited a chats
got no advice for us here we go oh look
at you where's you made it really hard
this game came out back in 96 I'm
developers didn't want you to be able to
get through certain things just easy
breezy there's the map hmm I don't know
if I want the man can go all right so
the room what crushes me it's good to
know ahead of time you got the map what
there's no Gameboy guide for Resident
Evil on gamefaqs man get on that guide
editor that we don't have anymore yeah
used to be me good on that passed me
maybe I can use the it's not necessary
well whatever then screw you
but I didn't just pick up the sword i
get the daggers I would I got ya okay
all right here we go here we go entering
Barry finds pulled blood exam the stuff
room fireplace you find the zombie and
there's a cutscene right back to Barry
main home whiskers gone but Barry why
were you here
okay go back to the main room Allah be
no no no no this is pushing the dresser
up to the statute we did that okay how
about a statue grab the object you're
now discovered some map to the first
floor take it now go back to the room
that the dresser was previously covering
walk all the way to the back once you do
this is on the corner you try to escape
and sounds like you should get the sword
key after that I fight is concluded and
I got the sorki do okay or maybe the
zombie prevented me from doing it maybe
it's like on the floor back come on come
out but zombie gets up every time you
leave the room by the way and pushes
that dresser back y ou shudi various art
supplies yay okay I feel like in my
inventory I go up to file cuz I got it I
got the thing
oh the daggers are limited use okay but
then you have a knife that you can use
yeah Keitel in a while since I've ok lo
the mini mystery okay so what does it
say that would I want my supposed to do
we're gonna when I have the sword key
okay I'll go back to the main room then
into the main hall right okay um then go
into the dining room ah and then and
then from the dining room go into the
room where you met the first zombie
right right right right I never you will
find the mangled corpse of poor Kenneth
oh god damn it Kenneth yeah you know
really I told him to be careful so many
times it's kind of it's his fault yeah
really it's your fault neglectful
Kenneth vegetable they always call them
that's what to put on this tombstone
would be n jill's tombstone God's
favorite sandwich your life jill jill
valentine may she rest between two
slices of sourdough sauerkraut and Swiss
cheese I feel like there's probably so
many good Jill Valentine lines in
resident evil 3 since yes she was the
star of the show they were probably not
taking into account here really this ole
boy might still be wandering around
somewhere so just be on the lookout for
that give me a [ __ ] Kenneth Kenneth is
not what that day beginning out why did
Kenneth bring the VHS tape with him
unless are your GoPros like transmitting
to some sort of VHS like tape recording
of like a VCR strapped to your back
gecko bros going into and then riding on
to these VHS tapes ok just have this on
I'm prepared to try to remember some of
the basics of CQC also watch out for
lamps ok Jill I need you to be like on
your game here I can't die halfway into
this trail though maybe that's the right
time to die halfway mastery I don't know
we can get lost on the Chris side of
things I'm just gonna look at this image
real quick this is such a good like
that's really good what a good setup for
what like a hell lies ahead of me so
good
look at that I know they're like look at
that delighting just look at that my
club just the slight off and go come on
because everything here is just slightly
off what the hell happened first of all
here's a giant as birdcage yes yeah
thank god that's your only wine you
think well yeah I just want an HD port
of this whatever I'll just plain an
emulator that's fine yeah I'll take the
herbs I also love how this game doesn't
had like a little sparklies everywhere
like you can use these people you can
use this up hey hey hey listen hey look
over here this is what's fun is oh thank
you game thanks I'm so glad you're
playing me mmm Joe can hold only eight
items because what you take i won't
combine it just yet oh is that is that
she's got a smaller satchel oh I think
it's no I do this thing I feel like
there's something about that though the
differences are seemingly small in front
but they are the other family huge
impact boys are on when you really need
to be taking those herbs with you but
you also need to take those bullets
here's got the air of am i right mm-hmm
420 joke all right this guy's a jerk and
he's gonna stand up oh yeah oh yeah I
also i feel like it's pretty dangerous
in an old mansion like this to have open
flames your main source of light oh this
isn't good oh yeah yeah that's a lot
from the other side yeah go check it out
what if I just don't want to what is you
up there's a zombie there's a zombie I
can seem in the mirror you sleep in the
mirror oh holy cow yeah there is the
silhouette of a zombie back there in the
mirror nope but he was a really pay
attention he's looking at his owner
footed diva oh yeah you might be a
zombie baby do you still got it I do
live examining things in this game and
it's also part of the thing that gets
kind of crucial mm-hmm go on go on could
you give an example I don't think you
can do anything with the arrow but there
are certain things we examine it there's
like there's a but I'm gonna push it Oh
Upsy i did go look at what i just did
all the puzzles up magazine oh so
beautiful oh come here often that's
totally do that get up stand that dude
come on Jill shower on Jill give him the
show oh I'm trying oh dude [ __ ] dude
guys reckon you it's good to not combine
those herbs I feel like this is the door
I want to go into I also feel like
damn it's just just I'm gonna use the
other one the other one safe and sorry I
can't say that I am you're fine all
right I guess you're fine now get over
it yeah sure you're fine oh man chat
really wants an HD remake tomorrow I
really want to ensure you remake as well
so good oh god just know oh okay wait
this thing is shining okay some things
are shiny I take that back and I guess
it's helpful that they're shiny thanks
game like I want to turn right back
around and just go back in is it gonna
tell me it's locked okay good are there
any lock like doors that lock
automatically when you pass through
there ah
I imagine probably during like boss
encounters and stuff oh it's a statue
that I push touch of my statue I wanted
that there you can't have her she's with
me we're gaining a chicken you're
playing with this guy nice what why did
you fire another round takes a while you
go I can you step on them and step on
dead check dead in this check Oh God
come on there you go an [ __ ] I get no
respect but sandwich what the oh yeah
yeah laugh it up oh it's hilarious Oh
line it up
so I'm in a big deal you've got to be
dead you're not saying for man in this
game like at least let me get my freakin
deck there there he bled out now you
know yeah yeah he's got the paleta
there's a dead sandwich
you're talking about Jack this dude
statue man what it he was a dick he was
kind of a big and like I know he's dead
now like for real for dead but I hope
his zombie go sees this hey all right
guys I push the statue down you know
what that means up is it time for a
break it's time for a commercial break
can only mean one thing I'll be right
back stay tuned oh they turn the music
off oh alright still going okay okay
Peter discovered something amazing while
you guys are gone let's cut to let's go
to the game feat here and check out
Jill's sweet foot action she's got going
on oh look at those moves look at those
sweet move she's a ddr champ that jill
valentine she can get triple a perfect
on mac 300 all right Dottie the brakes
wet oh it does it all right sorry I love
it use your foot off the music by
ruining the movement back to being
scared oh alright so there's a jewel
down there Jill fine it's locked a
nimble of sort I get it I need a
freaking sword key freaking frack I
don't know there's a good decision or
not
guess we're about to find out wait okay
this is where I came from yes go
everything I'll never actually check
this door though oh of course it is it
is locked from LOLOL alone so here were
you introduced to the resident evil
series through the first name like yeah
that's i was saying yeah my buddy had a
playstation before me and he he had the
original resident evil and i used to
play watch him play it actually his
house and then when it came time to
where i finally could get a playstation
i got that I got the original resident
evil and moral Kombat trilogy the
PlayStation and I scared the [ __ ] out of
myself I ended up returning the
PlayStation because I couldn't play
Resident Evil alone and I found that so
disappointing because I really wanted to
play something new so I returned it and
got in 10 0 64 okay and played super
mario 64 obviously yes and bomberman 64
definitely played that by yourself
bomberman 64 is a game I played the [ __ ]
out of there was no literally no there
was no [ __ ] left in that game yeah I
actually wasn't introduced to the
resident evil series until resident 30
well um yeah I was pretty late to the
party um probably because I didn't gosh
didn't know to play station until well
after it had already come out um but I
also there was a there was a very strict
no M rated games McGee household home no
first-person shooters no emerita game so
I was I'm so sorry disallowed from such
things but I had a cousin it's always
the cousin yeah I had a cousin always
the cousin who didn't give any apps
about any of that and he owned resident
evil 3 um and so when I would go and
visit him I would totally I would
totally play his copy resident evil 3
that came changed up so many things with
the whole nemesis mechanic oh yeah where
you get you couldn't just explore really
in a league it was like oh there's a big
boy there he is but that was really good
though cuz I'm in that game scared the
bejesus out of me just because just
because of the nemesis and always
feeling hunted and pursued yes the
nemesis was basically this big you guys
haven't played residen evil 3 was like
this big super zombie in a black trench
who sometimes had a rocket launcher
sometimes you didn't know
um but he would he would appear both add
set points during the story and then
just randomly as you were out exploring
yeah um and when he did appear like he
was way stronger than you way back way
faster um you could if you wanted to
spend like all of your bullets you could
you could temporarily disable him like
you could actually shoot him down he
would well you'd fall over but
eventually he'd get back up again and
start chasing you so it was really a
tremendous waste to do this he basically
just had to run away from him all the
time max you had like this deep growling
voice you could always hear them coming
were you hearing like stomping around oh
okay you like the nemesis but I need
instructions here okay hold on go back
out okay okay so you got the arrowhead
Riviera hood examine the arrow the arrow
head can be removed you have the
arrowhead you need to eventually where
you want to get to is the upstairs
dining room but it's okay so I was there
okay go back to the upstairs dining room
investigate the ledge find another
defense dagger which you did run around
the opposite side and see the zombie you
killed it yeah um you pushed off the
statue and get the blue jay okay it's
time to break stuff push the statue of
one back downstairs yep for now exit
dining room the second floor through the
double doors ok ok keep up with me guide
once outside run downstairs run back
down to the first set of stairs and look
closely at the wall do you notice and
inconsistency there's a small notch on
the wall do they meet up and that is the
entrance to the graveyard feel like
that's here yeah and it has a picture of
a grave we're gonna go do some tomb
robbing it does say once outside run
down the stairs which is cuz you got
that ok i got that fun all right i want
to avoid the zombie at there's totally a
zombie
and there's going to be a place where
you use the arrow head and the graveyard
that is your next challenge the vanilla
this is great guy throws an evil 3 super
spooky I totally figured it out like
right away I feel like I should have
been a sandwich by now little known fact
zombies don't know what stairs are they
don't look at this look at this look at
this so good so good yeah okay cuz we
wouldn't have this underneath their
house oh sure not gonna do anything with
that why not go examine that wall back
there okay yeah maybe maybe there's
something that dude this way he's always
should be that once the happy statue
everyone needs something wait so any
second thing we're going to fall is that
was trying to say we could lead there
should be a glistening object in the
room okay there you go oh yeah yeah look
of curse why wouldn't I I've been
looking for one of these got it got it
the book of course is very long spoiler
over hmm so there's a missing mask is
that there's a lotta sense now but there
there are the form asks are there is it
that it need to be moved somehow the
guide says just once you have the the
key from the book of her GTFO yeah just
GTFO the book of curse to the word of
curse
yeah you're going to go back to the
mansion and you're going to use the key
to open one of the doors
as a kid I also never really got
understood the art of avoiding combat oh
yeah and I would just die oh yeah all
the time if there's an enemy on the
screen you're supposed to fight it why
would just get so freaked out you like
yeah that's my only reaction you know
murder um okay judit tell its dad where
am I going with this key back to the
dining room it's somewhere in the main
hallway then main hall oh uh hold on ah
it just says go to the closer door on
the left side of the hallway hmm look
closer down it's just the dining room
over here maybe means up top maybe I
guess if you could use the key to open
it we do it on that so that's the dining
room it would
I need chat advice let you know hey hey
we did that in unison
can it connects Nick and I connect an
axe ok this is the do it I'll do it do
it do it canton gonna get you hugs
incoming Oh party time you to be Oh the
game will not let you enjoy your
victories nice nice avoidance I find the
are murky wonder if these people hate
living this mansion just like where did
you put the key this time Billy China
I'm novotel just trying to get to the
dining room i'm hungry i don't want to
have to go out to the Graveyard just so
i can get to our dining room haga living
in this man food I needed some herbs
whistle yeah the peaceful let me call
some dogs click
if you take are you oh wow we're taking
all this in all right John tolman taking
a real toll on me John yeah hey bullets
somewhere berries picking up an herb
right now and being like oh my i want to
carry this well what is this some basil
leaf I don't need no cilantro huh I mean
this book of herbs would be great if it
had like a sample somebody comes like
pressed a few herbs in it feels like I'm
not to it so good oh I'm a liver we're
possibly kidneys
got real spry they're on the phone
zombies can now he's gonna he's gonna
corny you and dude there you go there
you go there you go duck and weave oh no
pubes oh you gotta puke on you oh oh
yeah this is the this is the room where
you get stuck right ah seems to be what
the game isn't mine nope Peter do you
know anything about wasn't evil 7 no I'm
pretty sure you know pretty sure that
game it'll probably be a name at some
point but Pro maybe I'll be a facebook
game yeah for you to play facebook game
with mobled [ __ ] you can buy herbs
it's got second screen functionality
your Facebook dollars ok there we go
it's a good room this is a room where I
become a sandwich artist wait no yeah
thought that was the world full since
security maybe that you'll have to
double back through it and then the game
will spring the trap line yes I think
you're right actually
scroll back and the chat wants to know
what you think of evil with him so far
view scene yeah I've seen two different
sections of the game I saw a trailer for
it once that was really about it and the
trailer was really weird so I don't have
a bunch of opinion of the game yeah I uh
I actually I'm more injured in the game
now than i was at e3 e3 it had a very
like weird b-movie kind of tone to it
okay but the last two demos that I saw
at PAX East took place like one like an
urban environment and then another one I
was was inside that sort of dank like
sanitarium place that they should okay I
need interrupt the story real quick
don't I need that shotgun I feel like
there's no reason why you wouldn't want
to take the shot but I need everything
else in my inventory oh I mean I don't
think you need the shotgun in so much as
you need it to solve a puzzle I thought
you needed in this room I don't know
anyway yeah I think even what it looks
good i think from what i've seen which
is very limited so i have to take the
shotgun to become a sandwich that's true
alright so you do have to be here to you
have to take the shotgun kind of
sandwich there are item just know yeah
but I guess maybe I can turn around
maybe there's one on the other corner uh
even with it looks good i think it's
doing interesting things that sort of
slows the pace down its there's some
action like it resident evil you know
like five six but it's not as i get
stoned down you mean you don't have mass
zombie killing kung fu action no it's
but it's more like this game where you
do kind of like like slow kind of like
your calculated things or guys ditch
anything like twent i still need the
mansion key yes sign of the wisp later i
can combine ink with the lighter can you
get rid of your ink ribbons it's not
like you're going to use that's true i
could i'm just going to see I feel like
there's going to be a storage Chester on
the corner
um yeah i'm looking forward to be able
within I i hope the story isn't too
ridiculous because it supposedly you
know like takes place like in your mind
or whatever i don't know so dogs gonna
jump through these windows no well don't
call it out well this was the room was
let go from the windows I'm preparing
myself mentally medics mentally mentally
people in the chat are pointing out that
you should totally dumped your ink
ribbons all right taking a big old ink
dump you don't how I do not want this
thing just go away maybe examine it and
then does it give you the option now it
doesn't to be used with a typewriter
Thank You game 2 i'm gonna die so soon
there is definitely a zombie in here too
most def yeah i'm gonna see what it says
about this gross water yeah okay there's
gonna be something in here i need and
you're not gonna be able to carry it
I'm gonna shoot it because i only got
about 10 more minutes up the stream oh
don't get him Jill I really liked you
she's like you quit touching my leg she
literally bashed his brains out it was a
it would be really gross in that she
goes in to throw up and then like
another zombie dramatically closets and
we had a toilet it doesn't lay it's it's
cuz you puked in a jail you did you but
I just all so I just weren't good hey
thingamajig it's like a no one's dagger
dagger now head dagger huh man I really
need to figure out how to get a shotgun
looks like the waterworks toe like since
we're almost I just go into the room
shoot all of your bullets and then take
the shotgun but that won't even I still
won't have enough room learners you only
need to free up two slots because a
shotgun is like a biggin isn't it that's
not how this works that's only if you're
having to do the ant cash a case which
you don't have in this game it just
takes up a slot everything just takes up
the slide okay I'm gonna go down this
hallway first okay do it help you back
oh look at all this then hmm
oh so good something's going to happen
it's cool and prepared oh yes check it I
mean you're here this is the one
I can good music swallow oh did it it
did you did did it I think he's still
down for the count no I ain't good
Kickham you can go find those dogs yeah
I'm gonna fight the dogs you'd fight
those dogs get those and in arms
have they break through the window oh
wow totally not even putting at that dog
yeah get them oh no Jim defend yourself
Oh stab them Wow can establish these
that I know get them get them some good
dog shooting steel is precious China
I'm gonna get mint on this on eBay
I remember really odd things to do this
game I don't remember what actually do
people really want to see the duel
sandwich I really want to see the jill
sandwich getting really excited about
jill sandwich master of i'm walking all
right i'll definitely do the jill
sandwich as long as i don't die in this
room I'm no I'm not doing this not doing
this well know what there's probably an
urban there if you start thinking like
that that is dying words it's dying
words I don't know what you're never
gonna get yourself crushed to death in a
room do I get do I look for an herb no
you go jill sandwich go jill sandwich I
don't waste my ammo yeah 40 if sunlights
small bits to go through okay I could
try to find you an item oh no I just
closed it oh come on give it which way
is the room its back this way no idea
it's this door right yes sad waste all
my bullets man couch after I'll do what
I need to nope that's why I threw up
right
alright let's end it it's gonna do it do
it do it bruin these paintings they're
called frescoes letting off steam just a
lot of stress built off the zombie
apocalypse happening the home
everything's all keys and key locks Jade
arrowheads and it doesn't make any damn
sense strain for the Special Forces what
is this crap I all they do is they give
us these stupid GoPro cameras and these
VCRs have to lug around we don't have
walkie-talkies and wesker left to go do
his own thing and be way cooler and
everybody else I get stuck a berry berry
says to meet up in the hallway of
something happens all to everything
that's happened is it something what
does that even mean there you go what am
I even saying right now say right now
yes the shot in gun this is really why
we chose this game is just to get to the
sandwich to have this part happen let's
be honest
what's that rumbling I shouldn't be in
that sandwich
quick act like you're going to try to
save you something do something pretend
to save yourself do some epic Joe what
about over here what are you gonna do
what does this one do pull on the
candles no no secret thing maybe if I
shoot the role but maybe if I should
shoot it no open it no Peter you gotta
do something I'm doing all day yourself
save yourself oh the boy won't open what
I do
oh it's back up there Jill yeah and also
fell down yeah this is why Barry didn't
take the lockpick i annoy tip grab my
hand how about you just grab her hand
God give me your order still has to do
all the work she's so stressed out oh
you're down below this is immersive
gameplay design 101 right here so good I
see the count jumped up for the hall
yeah it was jill sandwich people knew it
was coming a second late you were to fit
nicely into a sandwich uh gross Barry
was this little e into a sandwich what
is it like a subway footlong what kind
of sandwich are you even had something I
wanted to check Carly basically he's
saying I had to poop quiet I'll go check
on that thing he's gotta go check all
that paperwork I was I was filling out
do we have to split up again Barry uh
yeah yeah yeah mom mom it's only gassy a
man carette nicely into a sandwich what
do I do after the sandwich can we do
that is there anything you can get you
any direction ah in three minutes what
can you do i I don't know I don't have
any direction for you exit the only
thing I would lead you to is try to get
you to item box you don't need that mean
i would like to die okay yeah that'd be
good have this dude yeah just do gobble
you up all right oh no no Jill stop
fighting for your life just give in
there you go oh I did not take long
blood you are dead and that concludes
this week's episode of megabit thanks
for joining us guys will be back next
week I think we're gonna play Jurassic
Park on the Sega Genesis like it was
fantastic yeah we're gonna bring a few
of us in here because a lot of us have
really fond memories of that game a lot
of people been asking for in the chat so
we're gonna ask what you guys wanted for
I don't know I'm saying here ah you guys
wanted bring it to you I check back with
gamespot tomorrow we're going to have
the lobby yep Bobby 2 p.m. pacific time
yeah exciting stuff there along with
what oh yeah multiple players comes on
today at 2pm as well yeah man today so
stay tuned yeah so thanks for watching
everyone take care see you on megabit
next Monday adios